assassin's creed valhalla is getting a
whole second year of post-launch content
kicking off with the crossover stories
dlc that sees odyssey's cassandra and
valhalla's avor meet but the first major
expansion for year two is dawn of
ragnarok in which aver witnesses javi's
adventures during the earliest days of
one of the most well-known moments of
norse myth and the following video we go
over everything that we learned about
dawn of ragnarok during a preview event
if you enjoyed the video be sure to
leave a like and subscribe to the
channel dawn of ragnarok takes place
after the events of the asgard and
jotunheim sagas so if you haven't gotten
that far in assassin's creed valhalla
and don't want to be spoiled this is
your final warning to pause this video
and come back later don't worry we'll
still be here
the asgard and yotenheim sagas conclude
with javi aka odin learning that there's
no way for them to physically survive
ragnarok however they can undergo an
experimental procedure to be born again
that's where assassin's creed sages come
from they're isu from javi's time that
go on to be reborn as humans knowing
that they and their allies will be
reborn following ragnarok javi faces the
coming end of the world dawn of ragnarok
picks up there with hobby seeking out
their son balder who has been kidnapped
and imprisoned within the realm of the
dwarves a land that has been consumed by
war ahead of ragnarok javi's quest will
see them once again face the frost
giants of jotunheim but they'll go up
against a more fiery foe too certa we
still don't know what abort's
motivations are in dawn of ragnarok only
that they turned to velka to relive
these memories of javi after having
vivid nightmares of baldur presumably
javi has a message for aver embedded in
their memories but we'll just have to
wait and see if donna ragnarok is
anything like odyssey's myth-based
expansion the fate of atlantis then avor
could be in store for a major
ramification or two donna ragnarok is
coming from ubisoft sophia the lead
studio for assassin's creed iii
liberation assassin's creed rogue and
assassin's creed origins the curse of
the pharaohs dlc
giles armstrong is senior scriptwriter
for donna ragnarok his other work
includes being the lead writer on
destruction all-stars and a writer for
marvel's guardians of the galaxy ubisoft
sophia told gamespot via email that
donna ragnarok takes inspiration from
the poetic edda and many of the norse
sagas the studio describes the entire
expansion as a 35 plus hour experience
which takes place on a map that's about
one-third the size of valhalla's england
though the expansion takes place after
the events of the asgard and yotenheim
sagas you'll be able to jump into dawn
of ragnarok even if you haven't
completed those storylines and although
you might be a little lost as to what's
going on ubisoft sophia told gamespot
that it has taken special care to make
sure that new players will be just as
engaged with the narrative as those who
have completed valhalla
[Music]
as seen in the cinematic trailer for
dawn of ragnarok javi will possess new
elemental and supernatural powers in
this expansion they will have the power
to command both ice and fire as well as
shape-shift regarding these new powers
ubisoft sophia told gamespot quote the
new powers add a new aspect to the
combat but not only they will alter the
way players explore the world sneak
around solve puzzles and also fight the
armies of muspelheim are dangerous and
deadly being creatures of fire players
will quickly find themselves needing an
edge over them sometimes they might need
to mitigate some of the incoming damage
and use the power of muspelheim to
temporarily become immune to lava and
flame in other situations players will
need to be on the offensive and quickly
shut down the enemy in all cases though
players should be on the lookout for
changing the powers acquired in the
hygge rip as the battleground evolves
end quote the hugo rip is the main new
gameplay mechanic in dawn of ragnarok as
its name suggests it allows you to rip
away and acquire the powers and
abilities of others it can only store up
to two abilities at once though so
you'll have to be strategic and how you
craft hobbies build some abilities are
aimed at stealth while others are more
combat or navigation focused when
designing this new mechanic ubisoft
sophia told gamespot that had two goals
for the hygge rip to provide players the
agency to play how they wanted and to
embrace the fantasy of playing as a god
who gains power by stealing it from
their enemies ubisoft sophia wrote quote
we wanted to really make a difference in
all players gameplay no matter if they
like face-to-face combat stealthily
taking out the opposition exploring the
realm of the dwarves in search of the
dwarves ancient secrets and mystery or
solving puzzles to get the valuable
treasure the powers will let odin reach
inaccessible locations give them new
stealth opportunities let them traverse
the world in a different manner and lay
devastation on the forces of jotunheim
and mussolheim activating the powers
costs hooger and old norse the term
roughly means the spirit the mind and
thoughts of living beings or their life
force all living things carry it and
odin can refill it by defeating enemies
animals draining it from hoogar blooms
or even sacrificing some of their own
life for hygge at shrines of yggdrasil
end quote beyond the abilities already
mentioned javi will also be able to
imbue their weapons with freezing
effects and raise defeated enemies from
the grave as allies if the cinematic
trailer is any indication javi will be
able to teleport to arrows they fired as
well outside of the story dawn of
ragnarok will include plenty of optional
content too such as a battle arena
that's run by a valkyrie where you can
take on different kinds of combat trials
if you're wondering how javi's gender is
handled in dawn of ragnarok it's
basically the same as it was in valhalla
in a statement to gamespot ubisoft
sophia said quote in dawn of ragnarok
players will experience a continuation
of avor story the rules under which the
animus operates remain the same and
players will be free to decide whether
they want to play with a female or male
character or ultimately let the animus
choose the stronger memory stream end
quote we also asked ubisoft montreal
lead developer for assassin's creed
valhalla why the latest mainline game is
getting so many post-launch expansions
as opposed to immediate sequels rather
the druids and siege of paris are both
each 7 to 10 hours long and dawn of
ragnarok clocks in at 35 hours you could
argue all three are expansive enough to
be combined as a whole new game that's a
follow-up to avor story in valhalla
ubisoft montreal could have gone for an
assassin's creed brotherhood or
revelations approach but chose not to in
response ubisoft montreal emailed back
to say quote to be honest it's a
question that we asked ourselves as well
for the team in general this felt like
the most cohesive way to give this
offering to the players the team has
made efforts to have all content be more
accessible to players expansions
included so they can explore the world
of valhalla not unlike a theme park we
wanted players to be able to choose
which saga they embarked on be it in
england ireland franchia and now the
realm of the dwarves expansions one and
two focused more on the viking facets of
valhalla and exploring avor as a
character under different situations now
dawn of ragnarok feels like the other
side of the coin where we go deeper into
the norse mythology and more so into
odin harvey's backstory and what we have
focused on giving players the ability to
play all the content in the order they
see fit we also felt it was important to
still have these offerings connected one
experience is complementary to the other
given how important norse mythology was
to viking everyday life we felt dawn of
ragnarok needed to be included in
assassin's creed valhalla end quote don
of ragnarok is scheduled to release as
paid dlc on march 10th be sure to
subscribe to gamespot to stay informed
on assassin's creed and be notified when
we post previews like this one if open
world games like assassin's creed are
your thing and you're wondering how 2022
is going to shape up you can check out
our preview for first spoken right now
but before you leave let us know in the
comments where you think valhalla should
go next in its second year of post
launch content do you think ubisoft is
going to stick to javi for the rest of
2022 or will we see a war story get some
further development as well
you